l'Ukraine continue donc d'être pilonné
par l'armée russe une attaque massive
sur tous les fronts par voie aériennes
terrestre maritime plusieurs dizaines de
personnes auraient été tué depuis le
début de l'offensive on parle également
de 100.000 déplacés les grandes villes
du kenyaniennes sont secouées par des
explosions des bombardements voyaient
les dernières images qui nous sont
parvenus les forces ukrainiennes font
leur possible déclare ce vendredi matin
le président
ukrainien vole des mirzelinski nous
retrouvons à Kiev tout de suite Gulliver
Craig notre correspondant bonjour
Gulliver où on est la situation on a
parlé de bombardement massif sur Kiev
dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
et en ce moment ils seront des
informations venant de
du bureau du président rapporté dans les
médias Ukrainiens il y a des combats
actuels en cours dans le nord de Kev
dans le quartier de obolun qui n'est
vraiment pas très loin du centre-ville
ils disent que c'est à côté de la place
tarasafchenko et
c'est ce qu'ils appellent un groupe
diverses de Russes je n'ai pas on n'a
pas pu pour le moment saisir comment
exactement ils sont arrivés là est-ce
que c'est des parachutistes ou est-ce
qu'ils sont arrivés par le nord parce
qu'on sait déjà que les forces russes
avaient pénétré la région de Kiev par le
Nord notamment en traversant en
traversant la zone d'exclusion
radioactive de Tchernobyl où ils ont
pris le contrôle de l'ancienne centrale
nucléaire de Tchernobyl alors on n'est
plus à dire que l'armée russe était au
porte Kiev elle est donc en tout cas
selon ces propos d'une source dans le
bureau du président ukrainien rapporté
par les médias Ukrainiens à l'instant
volody mirzelinski d'y être la première
cible de l'opération est-ce qu'on a des
nouvelles de lui et l'univers
la dernière nouvelle de lui c'est quand
il dit ça je pense on confirmant qu'il
restait donc qui est dans la capitale
dans le quartier gouvernemental bien sûr
le pays qui veut montrer sa
détermination à résister c'est invasions
russe a besoin que son président reste
dans la capitale il envoie très
régulièrement volody merzuelinski des
messages aux Ukrainiens et pas
uniquement aux Ukrainiens mais aussi aux
Russes on les appelant à manifester
contre Vladimir Poutine à faire quelque
chose pour arrêter cette guerre il s'est
quelques fois exprimés en russe qui est
en réalité la langue maternelle de
volodimeerselenski mais qui normalement
par l'uniquement en ukrainien quand il
parle publiquement parce que ça c'est
l'une des obligations des dirigeants
Ukrainiens qu'ils doivent parler
uniquement en ukrainien vlodie
merzelinski qui appelle russe et aux
Occidentaux aussi bien sûr de faire plus
je pense que pour le moment les
Ukrainiens sont un peu déçus par les
sanctions annoncées même si les opinions
bien sûr sont divergentes sur ce point
ils sont déçus mais ils se sentent
également seul Gulliver vous le disent
qui a déploré que Lucan était laissé
seul face à la Russie
oui et c'est le cas parce que les
États-Unis ont dit clairement que
militairement il n'allait pas envoyer
des trucs en Ukraine mais c'est un autre
côté l'Ukraine de depuis plusieurs
semaines depuis le début en fait c'était
de cette un massage de troupes russes
aux frontières de l'Ukraine l'Ukraine
reçoit beaucoup beaucoup d'Inde des
États-Unis et du Royaume-Uni et d'autres
pays aussi ainsi que du soutien
financier et je pense que vendredi on
est bien conscient il a maintes reprises
exprimée sa reconnaissance aux
partenaires occidental
occidental de l'Ukraine mais il est
clair que face à une armée aussi grande
que l'armée de la Russie l'armée
ukrainienne même si elle sait très bien
développé et transformé depuis 2014
reste une force plus faible que l'armée
russe et si la Russie est bien
déterminée à venir à bout de l'armée
ukrainienne je pense que elle a de très
bonnes chances arriver à le faire après
maintenir une force d'occupation dans un
pays qui lui est très majoritairement
absolument hostile et les Ukrainiens ont
promis de mener une lutte partisane de
résister toute tentative d'occuper le
pays ou d'imposer un gouvernement qui
n'est pas à leur goût
ce ne sera pas la fin de l'histoire même
si les russes arrivent dans un avenir
proche à prendre du moins de tempérament
la capitale merci beaucoup gilet vert
crade correspondante France 24 en
Ukraine